Mark Giangreco joining us on loan from
ABC 7 in Chicago and great to have you
mark how are you Dan how you doing buddy
long time yeah and I thought I was
thinking of you yesterday I rewatched
episodes 1 & 2 and I thought you know
what Giangreco would be great to talk to
because you're in a lot of shots you
were there through all of this and I'm
curious from a local perspective what
has stood out so far anything that you
don't know through four episodes
well no breaking news but there are
little vignettes where you forget you
know that it's not laid out
chronologically so you can't rely on a
timeline but there are all these little
things like Michael playing golf with
Danny Ainge before they took on the
Celtics in the playoffs or you know that
all access crew was in the locker room
for stuff that we were not privy to so
there were some very interesting things
and like you alluded to Jerry crowd
saying I don't care if you go 82 and Oh
Phil you're not coming back little
things like that and you know it's not
just me obviously you know every guy and
woman who's ever covered the Bulls
during that 98 season they're going to
get their face shot in there sometime
during this this documentary I have a
bet with some of my friends as to how
many times the tip of my nose you know
you know but we were with with them over
in France for the McDonald's tournament
which was great but again you know when
they won the trophy Michael's going this
doesn't count this is ridiculous and
they kind of just put the the trophy up
on the locker room shelf there and they
walked out like you know stuff like that
good you don't attention that year mark
oh absolutely no question I mean for
that to all come out before they even
started playing was just ridiculous so
again shown in the documentary Michael's
like stop dogging me about this question
I told you 500 times not coming back if
Phil doesn't come back Phil's not coming
back so I'm not coming back you're gonna
get the same answer but you know Dan
it's our job to just pound away and we
really can't appreciate this until now
it's taken 20 plus years to sit back and
say wow that was really cool to be part
of that because
when you're in it it's like oh we got to
get this interview we can't get beat we
got to do this live shot and I've
learned how to moonwalk backwards
chasing Michael Scottie and Denis up and
down hallways in every arena in the
country so you know you're just working
and grind it out and trying to keep up
with him and then you know it takes
years to sit back and go yeah I guess
that was pretty cool what isn't being
told well here's the thing and I thought
Ken Burns made a valid point arguably
the greatest documentary producer ever
I've been watching the Roosevelts and
everything else but look this isn't on
PBS it's on ESPN and just like Michael
and every other walk of life he controls
the situation his guys produced it he
hand-picked everybody he decides when
it's going to be released the whole
story is told through him and so some
stuff may have hit the cutting room
floor some stuff that maybe he didn't
want in the documentary won't appear and
you know the director Jason here you
know he agreed he's like yeah this isn't
pure journalism and I get what Ken Burns
is saying but you know Dan nobody cares
everybody's obsessed with it it's the
only thing that's going on right now the
ratings are through the roof so
journalism be damned I guess I also find
it interesting and ironic that Ken Burns
I think had nine episodes of the Civil
War we have ten episodes of Michael
Jordan our priorities are in the right
place we we need 10 episode 10 hours to
tell the story as opposed to 9 hours to
tell the Civil War oh absolutely but you
know this war lasted longer than civil
war I think I mean you know it was 10
years of intensity going through those
six championships and even you know
chasing Michael back and forth from the
batting cage to the field when he was
with the Sox in Sarasota
in spring training so you know I had to
do this thing with him as he walked out
of the batting cage and go to the field
every single day I walked with him and I
say Mike you got to stop dogging me get
off me I'm working leave me alone you
know you had to just play with him
because you know he was mentally
exhausted through it all we're talking
to Mark Giangreco he works for ABC
7-inch
how long you been in Chicago I'm in my
39th year man it's unbelievable
12 years with NBC and now 27 with ABC
who's bigger the Bears of 85 or the 90
Bulls oh great great question I think
this is still a Bears town I think
the aura of Ditka presides over
everything I mean Michael and an Iron
Mike are the two most iconic figures in
Chicago sports history I would have to
say still the Bears by a nose my nose
although now everybody is immersed in
the Bulls and they'll tell you well it's
got to be the six championships but I
think overall if you step back it's
still the Bears if you could have one
question answered by Michael honest mm
what would it be
tell me the truth about the whole
gambling thing tell me the truth about
why you retired and went to play
baseball you know and I think in episode
7 that's going to be addressed I'm not
sure but it goes back to if Michael is
controlling this and he gets the final
word on everything how much of like I
don't I don't think this is a total
epiphany where he's gonna go you know
now I can tell the truth is David Stern
gonna say anything he's you know he's
interviewed for this - David Stern
everybody has been adamant that hey Mike
did this and he wanted to play baseball
and I thought okay
at the peak of your career you want to
go play baseball they just get bored
with the NBA like how did you want to
pay tribute to your dad like we all had
those questions at the time and I was
there for his retirement ceremony in
Chicago where I go how is this guy
retiring it just didn't make sense it
still doesn't make sense that and the
whole Isiah Thomas and keeping him off
the dream team oh I know I mean we're so
jaded and cynical and we have to think
that he's not telling the entire story
and why would David Stern say anything
now you want to protect the shield as
they used to say about the NFL you want
to protect the NBA logo you don't want
to mess anything up now and have
everybody say oh my god you guys
lying to us we suspected this all along
it's just going to sit this way and for
Rod Thorn to say I love rod for him to
say that Michael never said a word about
Isaiah when putting together the dream
team I mean really and I remember uh
Chuck Gowdy our investigative reporter
was out at practice one day and pressed
Michael you know is that how you prepare
for a playoff game gambling in Atlantic
City he goes that's it
remember he implemented the media
boycott he didn't speak to us for months
and then finally one day at practice
were on the road I forget where we were
he looks at me it kind of winks it goes
all right come on let's do it
boom 500 porters dive on him and but
still Michael's gonna he's going to tell
the story the way he wants to tell the
story well what I really enjoy is him
cursing every five minutes because we've
heard him swear up and down in the
locker room in the hallway but this is
the first time on camera where he's
dropping f-bombs and I'm sure there's a
prop bet on how many once they get SEPA
sewed I'm not sure if we'll ever have an
athlete who will be this beloved in a
team sport I mean he was feared but he
was beloved and when he went to your
arena you showed up because you wanted
him to be great you wanted to see
greatness it wasn't one of those unless
you're a Pistons fan you showed up and I
think you wanted to be entertained and
by him and by that team you know we got
tired of the Golden State Warriors that
didn't take long for us to get tired of
that the Patriots we're never embraced
by America the Spurs were never embraced
the Bulls that was the that was the
amazing part of it mark where people
loved watching them even if it meant to
the detriment of your team no question
Dan and you know can you imagine load
management implemented in the 90s I mean
you know Michael showed up every single
night and he was aware that they all
came to see him he's not going to do a
Kawhi Leonard and sit out a couple of
games most of these people can't afford
these tickets it's a once-in-a-lifetime
opportunity to have Michael Jordan come
in town and see him live and every
player was like that in the 90s they
punched you in the face if he tried to
come in
and they felt an obligation to play
every night and perform and entertain
it's completely different now feel free
to not answer this but did you ever hit
the town with Dennis Rodman let's say I
was having dinner one night and he
rolled in with some people and this was
maybe 10 years ago not while he was
playing for the Bulls I wouldn't go near
him because you know I'm a moth to flame
but the first thing he said to me was
are you still here how he greeted he and
I said yeah man but always wanted to and
I think he would invited all of us to
come out one night but I think we were
scared to death I went out with him one
night at the crowbar oh yeah yeah I'm
driven by there decided you know what
I'm just not going to do it because you
know then I'm out of suspension I got a
couple years left on my deal and I can't
afford to get suspended anymore so we
don't need to go down that road of all
the times you've been suspended but yeah
I went out with Dennis I'll tell ya we
share the same birthday yeah Dennis and
Stevie Wonder and I and we're kindred
spirits in some really weird twisted
ways and remember the biggest being
Carothers men's store would advertise on
the building along the east expressway
in downtown chicago and they would have
Rodman's
mural up there it's giant face painted
and he was changing his hair color every
week so they had giant pieces of plywood
in different colors and they would just
change his hair every week I wound up
with one of those huge pieces of plywood
in my garage and I still have no idea
like got it it was the pinkish
chartreuse one and the thing was
gigantic it's like 10 feet tall and
about 15 feet wide but I think I lost
that in the divorce too he was he was
not a great interview but he was a
fascinating character that you know that
Scotty wasn't a great interview but
there was there was a lot of drama
surrounding Scotty Michael could be a
great interview
and then you had the other you know
underlings there the harp wasn't
necessarily a great interview Toni Kukoc
Phil could be at times but oh by the way
we had Charles Barkley on it and Charles
said that Jerry Reinsdorf has no blood
on his hands all the blood is on Jerry
Krause which I agree it feels like this
was all Jerry Krause that dis I build it
and I tear it down and Jerry Reinsdorf
the owner had nothing to do with this is
that real well no that's not real at all
but Jerry you know wanted to be a hands
off owner and so he kind of just let
crowds do what he wanted to do and he
respected crowds as a scout as a judge
of talent as a general manager both in
baseball and basketball he did he said
in the documentary you know I didn't
hire him to win any popularity contests
Jerry Krause rubbed everybody the wrong
way he was the little fat guy who wanted
to be part of the cool group and what
really struck me was we saw this all the
time but it just really stung to see it
again the Michael and Scottie just
abusing Kraus to his face and it got so
personal it was like you know he didn't
cross didn't like the media either
especially didn't like particularly puss
and we're like yeah you know this guy
was brutal but it's still stung to watch
him be berated by Scottie and Michael
like that is like ooh God but I think
Reinsdorf obviously does have some blood
on his hands for all of it you got to be
kidding it's just like rocky works in
the Black Hawks now Rocky's a hands-off
owner but he finally took it upon
himself to step in and blow that whole
thing up so Jerry Reinsdorf certainly as
accountable as the owner great to talk
to you mark and try not to get in
trouble all right
I won't Danny go Flyers the year that
could have been oh my god I know Mark
Giangreco sports director of ABC 7 in
Chicago really one of the great local
sports casters in history